It's time to play...
Serving Face. Serving Face.
(cheering)
Pareidolia is
the subconscious illusion
that makes you see faces
in regular objects.
Like in this pissed-off mop
right here.
What's he all mad about?
Comedians, I'm gonna show you
an object with a hidden face
from the twitter account
@facespics.
For 250 points,
I want you to tell me
what the object is saying. Matt?
Is that Marshawn Lynch
right there?
(laughter, groaning)
-Aw...
-(whooping)
First up,
this happy cup of coffee.
Doug.
Who wants to stay awake forever?
(laughter, applause, whooping)
Points. Matt Besser.
Cream in my mouth!
(laughter, groaning)
(whooping)
HARDWICK:
You guys!
Oh, I'm gonna (bleep)
give him points, yeah.
There's no question
that's worth points.
Next--
this suspicious pair of pants.
What's he up to?
What's his angle, Doug Benson?
(laughing)
If one more person
calls me Easter Island Face,
I'm gonna split.
(laughter, whooping, applause)
Mary.
(sighs):
You know... I'm just...
I'm not ready
to come out of the closet.
(laughter)
Points.
-(applause)
-Hmm.
Matt Besser.
Why does everyone "God bless" me
when I fart?
(laughter)
HARDWICK:
Yeah.
Next-- this celebrating stick.
Hurray! Doug Benson!
I just need the landing!
HARDWICK:
Oh, no. Oh, no.
-Oh, goddamn it.
-Give it to me!
All right, points!
Matt Besser.
(high-pitched):
I might be skinny,
-but my dick is this big.
-All right, points.
(whooping, applause)
(high-pitched): I'm packing
some serious wood down there.
All right.
Next up, this...
this hip-hop carrot.
(bell dings)
Mary.
Mo' bunny, mo' problems.
Yeah, points.
Points. Very well done.
Very well done.
Next, this angry kayak.
(growls)
Hey, Matt.
World's largest glory hole
open for business.
Oh, yeah, he wouldn't be
very happy about that at all.
Yay, I have something to stick
my big wooden dick through!
Finally, this super sexy radish.
Mmm, ah.
Oh, my.
Doug.
I know, I look
radishing tonight.
HARDWICK:
No!
Aw...
Points. Uh, Mary.
Put me in your butt
like you do
with all other radishes.
Points.
That is...
that is a really hot...
And you know you put radishes
in your butt.
-I've got four in now.